I see that someone super chatted saying
they want official Tim pool beanies we
actually do now have a large supply of
official Tim cast beanies however we
decided we're not going to be selling
them we're only going to be giving them
out to select members on a certain
case-by-case basis we're going right now
I think we'll be sending all of our
Elite members these uh these unique Tim
cassopinis that we have it says Tim cast
on it's got a picture of a little
gorilla wearing uh headphones and uh the
reason is I don't know if we're equipped
to do actual large-scale merchandising
just yet so for the time being we do
have them and we want to send them to
members starting with Elite members and
then probably uh somehow just basically
sending these people as a thank you and
then try and figure out how we can make
them special limited edition because we
only have I think like 200 or something
like that that's why it's like we can't
just sell them because they'll be gone
instantly and we want to make them
special so that you can only get them in
certain ways so